obrigado
muito boa tarde a todos mais uma vez a é
um prazer enorme estar aqui convosco
deixando só perguntar quanto os músicos
opções estão os roteiros muito ligadas à
música estão aqui nesta só temos algumas
não são muitas
então pronto eu vou eu vou estava de de
salvar um som cadu acerca de um percurso
é porque dá para posso dá pra entender
um bocado que contará a vida é
desenvolver e os objetivos que até eu
não tiro uma terra muito pequena chamada
nova castel que aqui perto que eu adoro
e então é crunch
não havia muito de música então desde
sempre
infelizmente uma parte de uma banda
tinha os instrumentos todos em casa
então eu pude começar a tocar bateria
desde muito novo tipo de início como
autodidata os meus irmãos também com o
teuto casar com ela amanhã e então é o
que acontece eu passei muito tempo a
ouvir discos de artistas e o objetivo
principal enquanto não não seria muito
pequena e esta tese o fato serviu
evolution é interessante isso porque
porque é um conceito que eu tenho vindo
a pensar bastante que eu estava num
sítio muito quente e o acesso à
informação não significa que eu seja
velho mas é é há muitos anos atrás deles
há 20 anos através da internet não
estava assim tão desenvolvida né e e
então a informação não chegava muito as
pessoas né ô ô ô youtube cada um caso
isto não existia inicialmente até então
o acesso à informação era complicado
começavam a aparecer vídeos de vez em
quando quando a internet com sua a ser
desenvolvida pronto e e o que eu acho
muito curioso nisso é eu sempre tive
mais tarde vinha ter muitas aulas e tive
vários
em portugal foram incríveis para mim
título foram são grandes referências e
clique me ajudaram a construir o meu
caminho e ao mesmo tempo é parte de toda
a informação que começava a aparecer
nós iremos também iremos vender o que é
que ia fazendo a forma como muitas vezes
ou seja de diferentes culturas quer
queiramos quer não de 300 idéias tão
diferentes apesar do instrumento você
poder ser o mesmo e da linguagem da
música ser universal mas conseguimos
tirar ideias muito diferente pronto e eu
na altura sempre sempre achei super
importante estudar aquilo que que
mandavam para estudar certo e passar
sempre muito tempo com o instrumento
tipo sozinho tipo criar uma relação é
criar uma relação com o próprio
instrumento com a própria música todos
nós somos diferentes todos os músicos
são diferentes
todas as pessoas têm algo para dizer e
na realidade enquanto a música enquanto
artista a tânia bateria para para para
expressar muitas vezes aquilo que ele
quer
ah então eu acho extremamente importante
termos e eu acho que isso pode servir
quer dizer nesta sala tenha certeza
absoluta que existem muitas muitas
pessoas que podiam estar aqui é contar a
sua própria história a contar o os
objetivos onde tudo e mais alguma coisa
e por isso eu acho importante porque há
muitas muitas situações muita muitas
idéias que são comuns a diferentes
profissões não é tipo uma das principais
ideias que eu quero trazer aqui a eu na
altura fui estudar pra nova york
tive a felicidade de ir para lá e então
estava estava a praticar e messi messi
tipo
e eu lembro de ter lido uma uma
mas dodô einstein dizia a molde lugati
formei club med net no hotel é oque é
toda a gente até de certa lógica
levamos um ponto a obra ou seja é que o
que eu na altura sentia era ok tudo
aquilo que eu estava a a aprender a
estudar artigo tudo tudo o que estava
escrito
ok isto faz sentir certo agora olhando
início através da imaginação e da
criatividade que eu acho que é o que é o
que nos torna individuais e é isso que
nos vai tornar de diferente né
eu acho que é super importante de
explorarmos essa parte não podemos só
porque nos dizem que colocar isso tem de
ser assim e assim vai ser para sempre
não ea idéia e vou falar em específico
nesse instrumento acho que é é muito
parecido como com quase todos os
instrumentos que é muitas vezes por
termos algo que tá que tá que tá as
críticas convencionado
ou seja muitas vezes praticamos
determinadas técnicas ficam assim mais
tempo é estudar e o mesmo exercício
mesmo veículo e às tantas
não sou nem sempre somos capazes de
pensar ok eu posso fazer exatamente o
mesmo esquema
vai criar um espírito santo 9 frente e
eu acho que essa criatividade
eu acho que é comum em muitas profissões
como eu estava dizendo e eu acho que nós
vamos dar as coisas vão ficar muito mas
acho importante que muitas vezes pode
pensar em suas casas mas a mãe e eu sei
que nós ficamos com pessoal - não vamos
fingir ministro espanhol josé luiz filho
não fizer de todo tipo eu acho que é
sempre que vamos captar agora firmado na
segunda parte uma espécie de chamas que
em nada atrapalha de jacinto contestação
que não podemos fazer e quer criar login
novamente pelo mesmo caso de chuva só
tem a ganhar com este governo organizar
toda a gente sabe mas às vezes nos
organizarmos conseguimos criar um
projeto à parte do nosso trabalho coisas
que nós conquistamos coisas que podem
fazer todo o sentido
ok então é uma das coisas que eu queria
falar é pequeno não voltar aqui com com
grandes filmes fez e também vou
aproveitar porque tinha que bater aqui é
mais fácil pra mim do que para falar
como você já deve ser e é tão eu
basicamente ganhando nesse conceito de
que a imaginação pode nos levar a todo o
lado
ok eu estou a desenvolver um projecto ou
desenvolver um projeto uma um método que
eu tenho já desde essa altura que
estudam é nova york e que basicamente é
estudar a bateria ou seja tudo aquilo
que deve estudar mas pegar em idéias que
muitas vezes são simples toque que
muitas vezes estão sempre a repetir
sempre sempre sempre a loop ok e a ideia
é aquilo que não sabe seja aquilo que eu
quero que vou exemplificar agora é
voltar uma música que vai estar sempre
100 para pedir e eu vou tentar criar
diferentes ambiente utilizando
diferentes peças de frentes diferentes
abordagens e eu acho que isso é super
importante da china no exemplo ficar ok
até do dia só que eu desligasse e
microfone um carro precisa começar e
depois é lei
[Música]
[Aplausos]
muito obrigado
nós basicamente o que estava a fazer
gostava de olhar já não se cuida aí
quero virar escravo e vocês falarem ao
máximo todas as cidades
não querendo me bater e eu acho que isso
pode ser outra gente mesmo não tendo
nada a ver com a música andréia mas eu
achei algumas algumas coisas testa sendo
que nenhum elemento que é se esse
produto da droga era dele né
será que é essa que é enquanto músico é
[Música]
o meu trabalho
a diferença
quem cai é um é isso que eu vi a criança
e izmailov faz seus olhos e eja sobre as
fãs cariocas andréa adversário fazer é
mais uma forma de exercer nosso também
seria para fazer mais e mais e mais não
sei qual é
por isso quero estar aqui
e estava próxima
[Aplausos]